respecting the result of the brexit
referendum means not just leaving the
European Union but the single market and
customs union as well that's what
Theresa May has always told us the first
phase of the negotiations made clear
that this would create a problem on the
Irish border but the Prime Minister has
stuck to her red lines and has chosen to
kick the can down the road on Monday
Jeremy Corbyn announced that the Labour
Party wants to remain in a customs union
with the European Union I think he's
right
a customs union is essential for
business and is the only way to resolve
the Northern Ireland situation but I
also think like many of his supporters
that he needs to go further and back
remaining in the single market - if
Jeremy Corbyn can make this happen
he'll be doing this country a true
service so can we stay in the customs
union we stay in the single market it
was all that about that nearly two years
ago what was it about what did we vote
for them what have we achieved or
attained from interstate selling
everyone out see this is the whole
problem with brexit when people voted to
leave they didn't say on what basis many
people asked assumed many people assumed
that they would be staying in the single
market many people didn't realize the
repercussions of all this and the
complications are so huge here we are
with the situation people many people
because I've spoken to people who've
said they're expecting a big fan and the
reality is that the Prime Minister's put
these red lines where these red lines
Prime is a single market red line and
customs union that we're leaving both we
boxed ourselves into a corner over here
not least in the Northern Ireland
situation and they're terrified of the
situation that there might be a border
again we cannot have a border the Good
Friday Agreement is far too important I
mean
to preserve I must allow the people in I
would just say that I wouldn't worry
boys Johnson has clearly got the border
issue sold although it seems to change
by our browser you've written
fortunately we don't really go in for
revolution or revolting on the streets I
do sense and come on Karen you're on a
stoop note the reason mr. Colvin is
suddenly who has voted consistently
against Europe and anything European the
reason he's suddenly embracing your line
is that he sees a vote coming later this
year he wants to Hoover up the dissident
Tories Hoover up the Scots now as
anybody else what are the half-a-dozen
Lib Dems or ever many they're on a
minibus get low lot of them bring the
government now that's the reality of
labour position has been evolving and
Jeremy Corbyn himself has a committed
that he voted to remain now he could
have done much more during the
referendum and if he'd done much more we
wouldn't be in this December Karen he
says in December he said quite clearly
we were going to come out of the
customer you need a single mother but
let's just talk about that speech that
was one of the most cynical calculating
treacherous speeches I have ever heard
in my life it was the neo-marxist the
lifelong anti-capitalist suddenly
getting into bed with the CBI
the the boss's organization the cabin
the capitalist organisation Frank Field
said it labor hadn't ratted on three
quarters of their constituents and which
with the hugest respect to you you sit
in a bloated unelected house that is
that is that is that wants to sward
bricks and I'm just wondering when when
your pals in there when remainer MPs and
when Whitehall treacherous Whitehall
mandarins who speak out against but then
saw negotiating against our negotiating
what you do because you weaken any
chance of a deal that we're gonna get
you weaken this country and the weaken
this you've insulted the House of Lords
a guardian of the nation service that is
respected around the world for its
objectivity in quality
[Laughter]
that one whoa first of all life as you
know I'm I'm not a Corbin astir but I
think that Corbin is completely right on
this and same as you Karen I don't think
he's gone far enough
I think we need the single market as
well as the customers you know what
bricks no that's the only way that we
safeguard jobs that we safeguard our
economy that we protect British business
and also that we actually protect the
Good Friday Agreement and then to add to
that actually Carol when you look at
about whether or not Jeremy Corbyn is
being cynical and whether or not this is
a calculated move the end of the day 65%
of Labor voters are actually pro-eu so 7
out of 10 considered 0-2 to leave stop
twisting it
75% of Labor members actually want a
second referendum yeah let's just look
at this crap now here we see that
outside of the EU is where the majority
of growth is trade with the EU is
becoming less important so we had this
is what exactly it's bigger and we're
becoming less reliant on it which is why
we have to take back our ability great
so let's just talk about this graphic
we've seen it first of all it just talks
about exports yes if we look at overall
trade we are net importers as a country
were net importer including from the
European Union whichever way you look at
it even if our proportion of trade
overall with the European Union is
declining it is still 50% of our trade
10 years down the road it's gonna be
more than 40% of our trade wait for this
on top of that nearly 20% of our trade
approaching 20% is with free trade
agreements through the European Union
with other countries including Canada
now Japan yes so we have got almost 70%
of our trade around the world through a
free trade through the European Union
and with the European Union now we give
that up and go after the 30 player let
me just finish is a really important go
after the 30 percent which we may never
get the whole of the Commonwealth which
I'd love to do more trade with is less
than ten percent of our trade countries
like India have free trade agreements
with free trade deals and audio easy and
then here's the other point countries
that already have free trade agreements
with with the European Union like South
Korea have said you can't just roll over
if you leave the European Union expect
us to get the same terms as European
Union that's 500 million people yeah
we're gonna renegotiate and we are I've
heard this from the horse's mouth where
India's concern the EU India free trade
agreement is far more importantly in the
aerosol in a UK India I'm like you June
I'm not a corbin supporter and
responding to something the kara said
earlier about this being a calculated
move reasons isn't dirty apology isn't
all politics calculated moves isn't that
the purpose of a politician to calculate
the best movie was amazed everyone
around this table knows I really don't
like the man but this decision doesn't
go far enough for me either by the way
but he's demonstrated right he's
demonstrated his grown half a spine now
if you grew the army house and his child
or prime minister if he grew the army
well yeah well this is what I'm about to
say if I can actually show the right if
he grew the other half of his spine and
actually embraced the single market to
somebody that never thought I could ever
ever bring myself to vote Corbin may
actually consider shaking his hat little
graphic you showed us
it said EU and non-eu now as well as
what Karen said which I endorse
wholeheartedly the other part so that
graphic is it says EU and non-eu so the
non EU part is the rest of the world
which is tens and tens and tens if not
hundreds of other countries right there
not one thing the money you is at one
block right so of course even if there's
a smaller percentage of EU that we're
trading with on what did you say imports
not expert exports or imports right even
if that's only 40% and 60% is the rest
of the world and non EU they that's each
individual country we tp'ed know but
that means that what we've got here is
the best best single market in the world
free trade quickly because Carol you
mentioned some Martin Donnelly and I
little kiss me now earlier this week his
comments were total he said leaving the
EU and leaving advocat single market and
the customs union was the equivalent of
trading a delicious three-course meal
and I think there's some European wine
in there for a packet of crisps yeah
even you don't look happy with only
somebody I've actually worked with when
he was in the foreign foxes the
Secretary of State for international
trades permanents I doubt he was
actually in the department international
trade here's somebody's saying you would
it was like being a fairy godmother if
you think you can